la vie fabrique des oubliés elles ont
décidé de vendre des vêtements pour
retrouver une place dans la société
une boutique éphémère un fil d'ariane où
ces femmes éloignées de l'emploi s'offre
une seconde vie c'est des donations en
fait beaucoup laiterie skis si c'est
encore utilisables en harley en rente ou
si c'est réparable le répare dans le
théâtre municipal elle ne joue pas un
rôle mais met en pratique leurs
connaissances grâce à l'association ou
lourd au passage 10 salariés ont été
formés à la vente par des professionnels
du luxe
c'est le cas de fernanda depuis plus
d'un an l'association des dards mettre
un pied dans la vie active donc en temps
ça vous fait 23 56 la vente s'était
toujours quelque chose qui m'a plu c'est
je n'ai pas eu d'expérience des
formations aucune formation mai
c'était la première opportunité de
travailler j'ai eu donc en france dans
une semaine
elle prendra son envol et débutera une
remise à niveau son projet enseigner sa
langue maternelle
l'espagnol mais aussi l'anglais comme
elle le chantier d'insertion ou du
repassage aide une trentaine de femmes
autour de deux autres activités la
couture et le repassage pour qu'elle
arrive
a expliqué ce qu'elles font qu'est ce
que l'association qu'est ce qu'on fait
au théâtre les créations qu'on peut
faire avec la couture ces formations
aussi un objectif c'est de faire
retrouver à ces femmes 1 estime de soi
les mises en situation leur permet
vraiment de
d'acquérir ou de réacquérir ce ca 67 %
de ces femmes accompagnées retrouvent un
emploi ou une formation à la sortie
créer une économie circulaire lutter
contre la précarité des femmes
c'est le sens de cette boutique éphémère
ouverte le temps d'une semaine